good morning we're in the locust topic
and yesterday we encountered this idea
of what is Louis it's somewhat the
combination of thinking about shapes
then formalizing it and calling it
geometry then introducing a coordinate
system on top of that and then trying to
encapsulate all of that in this one idea
that includes all the geometry all of
the reasoning through shapes to meet
some shapes that were very familiar but
maybe in unfamiliar ways like that
circle remember the last circle we did
twice as far from there as you are from
here so that's what we've been having a
look at and the parabola is the main
object that we focus on within this
topic of locus which is why we followed
on from quadratic functions now I want
you to remember with me when I asked you
to get out there on the serpentine wall
and trace out this particular shape it
was based on two fixed features on the
ground what were the fixed features they
don't want to give me one yeah sure okay
there was a line and then there was a a
tree so I want to own a straight line
and I want a fixed point okay
now what I'm gonna do is onto our
Cartesian plane here we're going to add
these on but now we're going to be
specific about what these features are
and actually named things and talk about
them in a way that allows us to
understand this and be much more
detailed about this not just like oh
it's kind of over here that thing over
there everything's going to get named
you're getting get a lot of tonal to
here okay so for starters let's draw a
parabola let's draw a parabola let's
just draw the regular normal prowl we
have which it has its vertex at the
origin no shifting or anything like that
so something like wrong color this
that's not bad okay now you could call
this y equals x squared I'm gonna leave
off telling you what it is just yet but
on to here I want you to think about
that tree and that lying on the ground
right and how we relate these two things
together when you positioned yourselves
I think you mostly found yourselves
around here and you all stood quite
close together it's hard the further you
go away the harder it is to measure okay
so therefore I want you to try and
remember if that's where the shape was
where was that straight line the one on
the ground where was it in relation to
the shape you guys traced down remember
where it was
hmm on this diagram I would say that way
you guys were positioned here the line
on the ground was kind of behind you
remember that in fact now that I'm
thinking back I wonder if it was a tree
I think it was me actually I think I was
the point okay so you've got this
straight line going along here and then
I said I want you to be the same
distance from here as you are from this
fixed point up here
so that was me okay now I'm going to
give you some names for these things
okay this guy up here around which the
parabola kind of will use you thought it
was a semicircle right but as you can
see if it's really a parabola it's not
that algebra told us that yesterday
around which it's focused is called and
originally the focus okay so this is
also called the focal point but this is
what the parabola sort of crowds around
okay then this line down here it serves
the purpose of telling the parabola
which direction the parabola is going to
be facing you right so if for example I
had positioned this line over here at an
angle like so can you see that the
parabola would now be facing in a
different direction I'll be going that
way rather than straight up and down
okay so being that it directs the
parabola we call it the directrix
directrix plural directress 'yes that's
a cool word okay so on this diagram here
we now have some language to describe
what's going on but there's more
features here and more things that are
important to us to try and understand
all of the different ins and out of this
thing so remember I told you that every
point on this parabola is the same
distance from the focus as it is from
the directrix the very shortest distance
between these occurs at the vertex can
you see that because have a look and I'd
love you to draw this in with me this
distance here is going to be the closest
distance to the directrix because
everything else is upward so it must be
further away if I drew all these other
vertical lines they would clearly be
further okay so this length here is very
important the length from there I should
have labeled this as well from the
vertex up to the focus also the shortest
distance from the vertex to the
directrix we call this guy the focal
length and I want you to notice it's the
same on both sides
okay so um excuse me this focal length
is a really important number to this
shape in many ways it defines what this
shape is so therefore we give it a name
we call it a right now this tells you at
least on this particular parabola this
tells you where the focus is right
because if I told you that vertex was at
the origin and the focus is a units
above the origin then that makes the
corner to the focus
what's the x-coordinate zero and the y
corner will be eight so for reasons that
are still inscrutable to me
the focus is by convention called s and
it's coordinates are 0 comma 8 in
exactly the same way since this focal
length is the same this is a as well
this length here so therefore I know the
equation of this directrix it's a
horizontal line in this case meaning its
equation will be y equals y equals what
negative a because it is clearly below
the axis okay all right looking good so
far
almost there we have almost all the
important pieces of information here I
want you to notice you've got the focus
and the vertex lying on the axis of
symmetry I'm not going to draw that in
for two reasons number one I've already
drawn it it's the y axis in this case
number two it's something you are
familiar with before we introduced this
idea but I just want you to remember
that it's there one other feature I
think it's 101 yeah one other one other
thing that I want to include here and
it's it's less important but it will
come up in some questions here and there
so you want to know what it is it has a
really funny name so I'm gonna draw the
shape first and then I'm going to give
it the name this hing here a horizontal
line that goes through the focus or I
should say a better way to say it is it
some line that's parallel to the
directrix and passes through the focus
it goes across and it's at right angles
to the
axis of symmetry it goes let me say that
again it goes across and it's a right
angles so get this the Latin name for
this when we say things are across like
when I say hey think outside the box a
formal name for that is called lateral
thinking have you heard that phrase
before lateral thinking it means like
think sort of sideways when we're
measuring the position of things on the
earth and we want to go across rather
than up-down we call that latitude right
they all come from this Latin word
lattice it means across right lattice I
said it was at right angles right angles
do you remember there's a shape there's
a kind of quadrilateral that is
characterized by the fact that it's all
right angles and so we literally call it
in Latin right angle does anyone know
the shape is the rectangle so therefore
we say it's a cross at right angles
that's the name that's what it's called
the lattice rectum
okay it goes straight across through the
focus it's parallel to the directrix now
I will let you work out we're going to
come to it in a minute I will let you
work out why the latus rectum is
important to this in particular I want
you to have a think about it's a length
we'll come back to that in a minute okay
here are all the important features and
on this basis we can work out the
equation of this parabola I said it
looks kind of like y equals x squared
sort of but let's find out what it
actually is
okay now let's have a look at this thing
I'm going to say there's some point what
am I going to call it it can move along
this parabola so I'm gonna call pay for
point and it's coordinates are X comma Y
because it can move all right so this
guy P the set of all points that P can
occupy is called the locus of this
parabola okay let me say that again the
set of all points that P can exist in
can be located at that is a valve aqus
so sometimes you'll be asked for the
equation of the locus they mean the
equation of the parabola okay